the business
hello everyone
um my name is Abhishek and today I'll be
talking about Computing homological
hitting sets this talk is based on joint
work with ulipower and Miranda Harvey
um so as we all know
um graph cuts are um
rough Cuts uh uh have a good presence in
theoretical compositions uh uh the
graphics have found applications in
clustering shape matching image
segmentation energy minimization uh and
so on
um and
um graph Cuts also come in various cases
like I mean SD card multiplayer cards
process cut and so on
uh our goal in this book is to
generalize the notion of
um exterior dissolution of uh cuts to
centricial complexes uh to keep the talk
accessible to a wider company science
audience I'll briefly recall some of the
elementary Notions in multiplied
topology
uh so here's my brief review of
simplication of marching so suppose
you've given a simple complex key then
we denote uh the P simplices of K by KP
uh
next uh we Define a p chain as a formal
sum of B syntheses of K and
um
uh for the purpose of the stock we'll be
working with Z2 coefficients so uh
effectively uh we can view P chains as a
subset of KB where KP is the set of P
similarities of K
um
now
um the the beatings of of the complex K
under C2 addition from a vector space
called the peak chain group of K and we
denoted by C subscript p k
um now next to Define
um
uh the the body boundary map so to begin
with for a Simplex for a p Simplex Sigma
is boundary partial P Sigma is given by
uh simply its set of P minus one faces
uh now the boundary map is then linearly
extended from P simplices to P chains
and this gives a vector space of
morphism from the B chain group to the P
minus one chain group
uh so continuing from the previous slide
we've already defined what uh partial p
is our boundary p is
um
um so
um the the kernel of this map partial B
is is is is called the beat-cycle group
of key and it's denoted by C subscript p
k and the elements of this kernel are
called the P Cycles
of of complexity
um the the image of this of the map
partial P plus one uh is is called
um the peak boundary group of Optics K
and it's denoted by BP BD subscript p k
the elements of the boundary group are
called P boundaries
the P homology group of K is obtained by
taking the quotient of z p k by bpk
uh moreover two cycles are said to be
homologous if the Z2 difference is a
boundary
and the set of Cycles uh homologous to a
given cycle Zeta is known as the
homology class of theta and it's denoted
by a square bracket Theta
finally a certainly there is also a
boundary is called a bounding or a
triple suffix and a second there is not
a boundary is called a non-bounding or a
non-tribute section
okay
uh now that the review is over let's do
a simple example to build some intuition
um
so in this example you see a planar
complex uh with with a with a hole in
the middle
um the the inner cycle uh
the inner cycle Zeta one
uh rather the inner second Theta 2 is
depicted in bubble and the outer cycle
Zeta one is depicted in blue and as you
can see
um for Zeta 2 minus Zeta 1 is the is a
boundary and the it's in particular is
the boundary of the triangles that are
shown in pink
so for this example Zeta 1 and 0 are
actually homologous
um so this completes my description of
this example
um uh
and next we will recall some Notions uh
related to surfaces and because surface
is constitute an important class of
simplified complexes
and also we have some results for
surfaces
um so many of you must have encountered
surfaces such as the cylinder the
mortgage strips here uh Taurus client
model real uh protective plane and so on
and
um off of these surfaces the surfaces uh
with boundary are the cylinder and the
Mobi strip and the surfaces without
boundary are
The Climb bottle and the real projector
plane
um and next we'll look at the definition
of simplicial surfaces which are
basically triangulations or surfaces but
to begin with we Define the star of
Robotics of complex
um so the star of robot x v is the sub
complex of uh consisting of all
syntheses containing vertex V along with
their faces
and
um a triangulated surface is a central
complex in which the star of every
vertex V is a sufficient disc so
basically locally it looks like a plane
um
and a closed surface is a surface that
is Compact and without boundary
so
um in context of this book the surfaces
that are interesting are closed surfaces
that are triangulated
uh all right now that the preliminaries
are over uh let me go to what was
promised in the first few slides that
we're going to generalize main SD card
about main card
um so let's let's try to do that now so
recall that Ministry cut asks for uh the
minimum number of edges whose removal
disconnects s from t
um
um and equivalently we can say that it's
the minimum number of edges that need to
be removed so that there is no path
connecting SMD
however there is a path connecting our
vertex what there's a path connecting
vertex s toward x t if and only if the
boundary of uh the path is S Plus T so
the homological formulation of the mid
cut problem when a sticker problem is uh
what is the minimum number of edges you
need to remove so that S Plus T is not a
zero boundary
um
now the image is generalization of
monastic complex is a problem that we
call boundary non-tributalization
so let's try to understand what this
means through an example
so in in the example shown here on the
slide
um if you have a complex L which
consists of triangulation of a union of
two spheres that intersect in the circle
um the circle of intersection is denoted
by b i which you probably cannot see
because the font is too small
um and uh the question is well what is
the minimum number of two simplicities
you need to remove so that b is not a
bounding cycle anymore so why is it a
bounding second because you have two
caps in the top and two caps in the
bottom and for each of these caps B is a
bound exactly so you need to remove
simplices so that b is not a bounding
cycle anymore so the minimum number of
uh trying to set possible two syntheses
that you need to remove is of course
flow you need to remove one two Simplex
from each of the caps and then B is not
a bounding cycle anymore
now
um
yeah this example completes my
description of this this problem uh I
will not say more about this problem
because we don't study this problem in
this paper actually but I only described
it because it's a direct generalization
of an SD card but actually we explore
this problem in more detail in the
extended version of a paper which is on
archive instead we look at the Dual
version of this problem which is called
the homological hitting set
and for the remaining remainder of the
talk this is what we'll talk about dual
problem which is homologous
all right
so what's homologous heading set
um so uh before I I formalize with the
definition let's once again look at an
example so in the example shown in the
slide you have a planar complex scale
and two cycles are depicted Zeta and PSI
and
um the the second Theta is depicted in
in green but there's another cycle
that's homologous to Zeta that's also
depicted in green
now
um so the question is well what is the
minimum number of simplices you need to
remove so that the class of uh Zeta is
destroyed uh equivalently what is the
minimum number of simplices or what is a
find a set with Optimum cardinality set
of edges of minimum cardinality such
that
um uh every cycle in the class of Sita
meets an edge from this set so if you
look at uh in this example if you look
at the set which is shown in red if you
remove this edges then the class knows
it has destroyed so okay so that's
that's what is homologous homologous
problem now this is a cut problem in the
sense that finding a minimum cut or in
this case a minimum hitting Set uh is is
equivalent to removing simplices from
the thin portion of the complex
now let's try to make a formal
definition of the parameterized version
of the problem so you give it a complex
key and uh and a an integer a little K
and uh this integer okay bounds the the
uh the size of the the parameter which
is basically the solution size so so
what you're saying is that the goal is
to find a set s of R plus one simplices
whose cardinality is bounded by K such
that s meets every second model is to C
diff
uh so as I talked about an example
before of course if you remove as uh the
set of simplices s from K then the
classroom Theta will be destroyed
um all right so now that the uh the
problem has been described let me very
briefly recall some of the elementary
Notions in parameterized complexity so
that I can demonstrate the results
um so recall that in parameterized
complexity along with the instance and
the question you have a third uh bullet
and that's the parameter and basically
you see that your parameter is bounded
by some integer key so you expect the
parameter size to be small foreign
algorithms in this context are
algorithms that run in FK multiplied by
the end time where f is any computable
function of the parameter K and P is a
polynomial polynomial function of the
instant size n
um now the classes uh the complexity
classes in this context
from a hierarchy from w0 to through W1
through W2 to WP and then XP and so on
uh and the tractable class is actually
fpd or which is same is not to zero and
the interactable classes are the ones
shown in dark blue which is W1 through
XP
um so when you want to show that a
problem uh it does not have an fpt
algorithm you basically want to show
that the problem is W one Hardware too
hard over XP harder so on
and the way to do this is to reduce a
known uh W1 or WP heart problem to the
problem at hand and this reduction has
to be an fpt reduction
okay so that completes my description of
the preliminaries let me now State the
contributions
um so as of as a first result we have a
polynomial time algorithm for computing
the minimum homologous relating set for
surfaces
as a second result uh we show that the
problem is W1 hard and hence also NP
hard for generally complexes
uh so by the way it's w one heart with
respect to the solution size which is
also called as the natural parameter
uh to complement the second result
um we show that solution size plus
degree of the phase percent of the
complex if you take the solution size
plus a degree of the Facebook set as a
parameter then we have an fpt algorithm
so there are many uh there's a there are
families of complexes that are
interesting for which the degree of the
phase percent uh is bounded and
um
uh so that and in that case you get a
true fpt algorithm uh in terms of the
national parameter
um all right
so now I'll make few remarks uh about
the contributions so first let me see
that the polynomial time Solutions and
substances largely depends on the
structural result for surfaces and
structural result is that minimum
homologating set is always a co-cyclic
so remember that what we're trying to do
is we're trying to destroy us destroy
cycles and the Optimal Solutions
actually happen to be duals which means
Co seconds
um so to complement the structural
result we
provided an explicit example of a
two-dimensional simplest complex for
which the Optimal Solutions are not
cosines
uh and of course these uh two complex
this two complex is actually not a two
not a surface
um then uh we we show W1 hardness of
molecule hitting sets for General
complexes and this is done via an fpt
reduction from a known W1 heart problem
called automaticolored click problem uh
the reduction is fairly complicated and
surely you cannot recover any talk of
this length so that is all I'll have to
say about this this result
and finally
um we show that uh so finally about the
fpt algorithm I would like to see that
we uh the fpt algorithm relies on
another structural result which is that
uh any minimum homological hitting set
induces a connected subgraph in the face
portion of the complex
and
um because of this we know that the
solutions are connected in some sense so
what we actually do is that we just
enumerate connected sets in the face
posit and this Brute Force integration
already gives you an fpt algorithm uh
with respect to Solutions I specifically
okay so that completes my description of
the contributions
uh I would like to uh now describe the
algorithms to surfaces in more detail uh
because it's the simplest one and hence
uh in many ways most appealing one
but before we do that I need to uh
review some of the Notions some
some more preliminaries specifically uh
related to chromology
um so here's my preview so
um once again suppose you're given a
special complex K and uh then KP denotes
the set of P simplices of K then the P
chain B quotients are uh simply the
functions going from KP to Z2 since we
are working with zero coefficients P Co
chains can be equivalently viewed as
subsets of KP
um the the P code chain of a complex uh
the the big coat chains of the complex K
under 0 addition form a vector space
which is called the beat cochain group
of K and we denote this by C subscript c
superscript p k and
um now we Define the co-boundary of uh
map uh so first the co-boundary of a
Simplex the co-poundary map applied on
the Simplex is uh just the set of p plus
one cohesives of that simplex and then
if you linearly extend this map from P
Sim to C to P Co chains you get a vector
space from amorphism from uh the beat
cocaine group to the P plus one coaching
group
um yeah so uh rest of the uh Vector
spaces are defined in terms of the curls
and images of these Maps
um so uh continuing from last line the
kernel of the map uh uh Delta B is
called the pit kosaki group of K and
it's denoted by c superscript p k
and the elements of this girl are called
the Pico Cycles okay
uh and the images of the map Delta P
minus one
uh uh the image of the and the image of
the map did the P minus one is called
the co-boundary group The Boundary group
of K and it's denoted web APK and the
elements of the commander group are
called Pico boundaries
um
the big homology group of K is obtained
by uh taking the quotient of CPK by VPK
and now we need once again a few more
additional definitions which were kind
of dual of what we saw before so two
core Cycles are common always if there's
a two difference is a boundary
um uh the set of core cycles that the
model is to a given cosine Z
is called the commodity class of c and
it's denoted by square but I can see
uh then Aqua cycle there is also a
co-boundary is called a trivial co-cycle
or co-cycle that is not a boundary is
called a non-tradeleco cycle
all right uh now once again to build
some nutrition let's go through an
example so the the set of edges are
shown in purple actually form a cosychic
this is because uh the the set of Echo
Cycles okay uh so first let me describe
the complex the complex is is a square
that is triangulated so it basically has
no holes
um and in this complex you're given uh
the the edges in bubble uh is a co-cycle
because uh If You observe uh the
populations are incident on uh every
time the even number of times it's
incident evil either zero times or two
times so if it's incident uh so because
of that it's a two second
and um also that this co-cycle is
Trivial because it can be written as the
co-poundary of the vertices in blue
okay that completes my description of
the example
um I hope this built some intuition for
for cohomology
um now uh one final thing that connects
homology and chromology and this is a
very nice construct it's called the
evaluation map so let me see what that
is so if you're given a co-cycle z
because Z and a second Zeta then you can
evaluate uh Z on Zeta and the evaluation
is simply the sum of uh Z evaluated on
every Simplex that belongs to uh the
cypruseta
and because we are doing uh Z2 editions
uh the evaluation of cocycle Z on a
cycle Zeta uh is either 0 or 1.
um
moreover this evaluation map is
non-degenerate this is a very useful
property and what this means is that a
COS cycle Theta is Trivial if and only
if it evaluates on every cycle on every
piece of Zeta it evaluates to zero
and model on the other hand cycle Zeta
is Trivial if and only if uh Z of Zeta
is equal to 0 for all Pico Cycles C okay
so this is the this completes my
description of the evaluation map now I
think all the preliminaries are covered
uh oh there's one more left it's called
the chromology basis uh with Z
coefficients so uh let me say what that
is so a set of cosecles Z1 to zg is
called a commology basis if the set of
classes square brackets Z1 to square
back and CT form a basis for the first
chromology group of K here by G uh here
I'm denoting the dimension of the first
chronology group Apache
uh so this is what I mean by a comology
basis it's a set of cool cycles that are
non-trivial and non-linearly dependent
now the rate of cocycle is
um the sum of weights of the edges in
that coselling
the weight of a common multi basis is
the sum of the weight of the basis
cosightings
and
um a minimum commonality basis is a
commodity basis of minimum weight
um now an important fact about uh cop
homology basis is that they are they
have the the set of comology BCS for the
commonly BCS form a Metroid structure
and this is something we exploit
algorithmically
um
so now I'm ready to describe the
polynomial services so our example of
the surfaces goes as follows so
um you are given an input second Zeta uh
you find a minimum chromology uh basis
uh of this input cycle then you arrange
the co-cycles in in the basis uh in the
ascending order of weight and then you
pick the smallest circle cycle Z that
evaluates to one on this cycle
uh so here what here in the last line Z1
to Z K minus 1 evaluate to 0 on on Zeta
and z k is the first one that evaluates
to GK is the first cosecond that
evaluates to one
um on second Theta and that's it that's
the optimal that's uh an optimal uh
homologous creating set
so why does this work so it works
because of uh some nice levels uh and
let me first describe this so the first
nice structural demo is that a minimum
multiplication set is always a
non-triple cosychic and that's because
uh and this is something that follows
from two facts one is from because
you're assuming the hit except to be
minimal and it also follows from the
non-degeneracy of the evaluation map
the second uh crucial demo to prove the
correctness is that uh if you have
cosecles z i uh from I I is equal to one
to k then
um and if all of them are not minimum of
homologic sets for Theta then any linear
combinations of these co-cities is also
not a minimum a minimalating set uh so
this is uh this also follows from the
non degeneracy of the evaluation map
uh now the correctness of this algorithm
now we use the correctness now we use
lemons one and two and the correctness
follows from the fact that
um so if Z1 to Z K minus one are all
evaluating to zero in CK is the first
one that evaluates to one then we know
that Z one to c k any linear combination
obviously one to Z K minus one also
evaluates to zero and is not an optimal
hitting set so uh and then by the
Metroid property of comology base is ZK
is the minimum weight cycle uh or
minimum weight core cycle that's
linearly independent of the preceding
Cycles and that's why it's uh the
optimal core cycling or the optimal
hitting set because it's a core cycle
and the first one uh that evaluates to
one uh
on on uh on the protective
all right so I hope uh this gave a
flavor of the algorithm and its
correctness and um I would finally like
to conclude the stock and uh for
conclusion I would like to say that
although uh there was some discouraging
result about uh uh you know about the
complexity for General complexes which
is that it's w one heart and the natural
parameter and it's NP hard and so on uh
there is still a lot of Hope for for
algorithmic exploration for this
construct because uh for important
classes of complexes like surfaces and
manifolds if you have polynomial type
algorithm and also the the algorithm is
and also we have an fpt algorithm the
natural parameter uh when the degree is
small and there are interesting families
of complexes like cubicle sets for which
the degree small so um so we have some
kind of tactibility uh for interesting
classes of complexes for for this
problem called homologating sets
and uh finally as a final Mark I would
like to see that this is not just all
theoretical and uh we're looking into
um
applications of this construct uh in
establishing uh robustness or in
quantifying robustness of pockets in in
biomolecules
um with that I'd like to conclude my
talk and I hope uh this wasn't enjoyable
talk and thank you for your attention
foreign